haters have one job it's to hate that's
all I do you you're all on social media
you have a lot of Millennials in here
it's people just troll to say something
negative I don't care what you do what
you post I don't understand people like
that but people hate because they
jealous if you really want to be
successful you gotta have a lot of dog
in you
you got to be mean sometimes because
life ain't Fair life is hard man it is
not fair
like you have happened to you to just
you go man why this happened cause life
ain't Fair but life ain't fair to nobody
you just gotta fight through man you
gotta you gotta bite back sometime it's
like haters when you get haters people's
opinion of you is none of your business
they say it but they don't even know me
so I don't I don't give them no energy
so I just I just keep going through and
but then I tell you something too haters
motivate me
because when they talking about me that
means I'm doing something
if you have no haters if you don't have
any haters
you need to get some
you need to get some haters because if
you have no haters and
you ain't doing nothing man there's
times I felt like giving up
I mean no matter who you are if you have
a goal in life
everybody has a turn back moment
everybody has a crossroad if if you
haven't been at it it's coming you can
either decide to continue
or to quit
to go forward or to go back you're going
to always have that decision
but what I did was I made all of my
dreams bigger than my fears
so when I felt like quitting the results
would have been devastating to the goal
I was trying to attain see I was so sick
of being poor my motivation was I was
just exhausted from poverty I I couldn't
I couldn't do this no more
I was sick of living in my car
I've been living in my car for three
years I was sick of not having money I
was sick of not having a bathroom a
front door and so for me to quit and see
that's what people do people quit when
they set their hardest moment but if
it's at your hardest moment why would
you quit somebody sent me a plaque one
time that said If You're Going Through
Hell why stop that I mean think about if
you're going through hell why stop that
you inhale move keep going and I just
could not see myself not being
successful and so since I was already at
my lowest point how much lower can I go
I figured if I quit I go lower than that
I didn't need that today now everybody
wants somebody to think the same thing
otherwise they're evil or otherwise they
could hurt me whatever happens sticks
and stones will break your pose the
words will never hurt me we have this
whole thing that words are evil words
are action word it's both
and all it does is make you incredibly
weak as a human being and you're more
than that we all are more than that but
you know what like a kid that's never
broken their bones definitely afraid of
breaking the bone but if you're a kid
you're rough and gumbo you broke
multiple bones they heal you don't have
any fear of it there's so many kids that
have been raised to be safe and secure
every moment anything that's insecure
unsafe they don't want to be a part of
including language
and what it does is make you incredibly
weak and fearful and that's why there's
so many people that are abundant that
are angry all the time
because they're angry because they're
not growing so don't get me wrong I know
some people are not a good influence I'm
not denying that I'm just saying you're
more than somebody's influence unless
you obsess about it every moment and
make them wrong so you can make yourself
feel Superior morally psychologically or
spiritually and it's stop the
pattern we've all done it catch yourself
because if you want joy happiness and
freedom and extraordinary life it will
not come from blame never there's no
Pride that comes from blame I don't mean
fake Pride where you make to feel good
I'm talking about real pride pride is
something you earn like people tell me
oh I have no self-esteem because my
parents used to say this or they'd say
that I'd say that's such I'm
not saying they didn't say that
I said it's that's why you know
you stop esteem self-esteem does not
come from what people say about you
self-esteem comes from what you
experience about yourself and you learn
to grow you go there in my life someone
can get your goat if someone can piss
you off if someone can make you feel
less than
that's God coming to you saying grow you
need some spiritual growth there's got
to be some change in your perception
your belief your emotions your spiritual
look of life so that can't happen
anymore and when it happens like at 61
I've been through so many of those
things and I like to do things in Mass I
took on big challenges so I'd have to
grow more
but then life throws them at you too
when they come you just go okay it's
gonna have me until I grow what needs to
shift in me so that no longer has an
impact and this is what I love about my
haters you know and I just believe you
can you can get something out of
everything you know I think everything
teaches if you're with a three-month-old
if you pay attention they're teaching
you something I mean it's something you
can get out of watching this
this three month old is not concerned
about time you know I'm saying he's not
he's not on the etiquette thing I mean
he's just living free you know and so
for me the one thing I love about my
haters uh is they give me a perspective
that my mother doesn't give me my mom
loves me so much and I think you know
there are times where you know she may
want to correct me and she's like I
don't want to hurt his self-esteem you
know you know my wife you know may not
say a certain thing because you're like
I'm not 100 sure I'm not in the field
maybe I shouldn't say that but I find
that my haters say what's on their mind
you know and sometimes what they say is
is real you know that there's some
adjustments that I need to make you know
now I don't take their hate and allow it
to tear me down but there are things
that they say you know about me I never
forget this one guy who was hating on me
was talking about how I had four or five
jobs you know he's like he's doing this
and he's doing that he's doing that and
I thought about it one day I was like
okay what is he saying now take away
that he's not making his dreams become a
reality and he's jealous about the fact
that I'm fearless that I'm going out
here and I'm trying it but there was
some validation in what he was saying
and that if you're doing too much and
you don't have a solid Focus you may not
be getting the most out of your life and
I was like you know what this guy's he's
telling the truth and so I started to
narrow my focus haters have given me
that extra that edge that advantage that
I know that they're always in the
backdrop waiting for me to make a
mistake they're waiting for me to fall
they're waiting for me you know to come
out with a video that doesn't represent
you know the videos I've done before
they're waiting and so um I'm gonna keep
them waiting a gentleman who
dramatically transformed my life I was a
junior at Booker T Washington High
School in Miami Florida and I went in
his class looking for another friend and
and he said go to the board and work
this problem out for me I said sir I
can't do that he said why not I said uh
I'm not one of his students he said do
it anyhow and and the other kids started
laughing saying he's Leslie he's DT and
he said what's DT he's his brother is
smart but he he's the dumb twin and and
I said I am sir and he came from behind
his desk and he pointed at me said don't
you ever say that again someone's
opinion of you does not have to become
your reality and he taught me three
things he said it if you want to become
successful in life young man he said
number one you got to change your
mindset he said you don't get in life
what you want you get in life what you
are number two practice oqp only quality
people you earned within two to three
thousand dollars of your closest friends
I found that out I left all my broke
prayers I said y'all gotta go
because I used to be so broke I passed a
bank and tripped the alarm you know
and the third thing he said develop your
communication skills because once you
open your mouth you tell the world who
you are and that's there it is out you
know there's so much going wrong and
going off in this world
that if people can focus on themselves
being better versus throwing hate and
all this that happens out there and
people talking around I won't miss no
his names that's trying to hurt you man
but I'm trying to be the standard and
sometimes life is just not fun when
you're like can't do that can't say that
you gotta watch out for that yeah I
gotta wake up today I gotta I gotta
grind because there may be a God that
sees me in the car that says all right
I'm gonna go home and be better today